[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marieta Slomka guten Abend
unmittelbar nach dem Überfall Russlands
auf die Ukraine wirkte die deutsche
Politik wie aus dem Schlaf gerissen
plötzlich geschahen sehr viele Dinge
sehr schnell der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister etwa raste los
und kaufte Gas ein
lng-terminals wurden aus dem Boden
gestampft für die ist normalerweise
wahrscheinlich ein rund 100-jähriges
Baugenehmigungsverfahren gegeben hätte
der Bundeskanzler verkündete die
Zeitenwende und machte mit einem Schlag
100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr locker
doch da hatte er die Rechnung ohne das
Beschaffungswesen gemacht das ist
offenbar noch im friedensmodus
ausgegeben wurde von diesen 100
Milliarden bisher praktisch nichts nada
die werbeauftragte die heute ihren
Jahresbericht vorlegte nennt das
erschreckend aus Berlin
sie bleiben oftmals zurück ohne Gerät
seit dem Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
gehen schützen und Kampfpanzer Munition
und Haubitzen in die Ukraine und zwar
ohne das zügig für die Bundeswehr
nachbeschafft wird die Bundeswehr nicht
voll einsatzbereit die Lage prekär die
Bundeswehr hat von allem zu wenig und
sie hat seit dem 24 Februar 2022 noch
weniger das betrifft die Ausbildung das
betrifft die Übung und das betrifft auch
die Ausstattung im Einsatz kaputte
Kasernen fehlende Ausrüstung behäbige
Beschaffung altbekannte Probleme Liste
die werbeauftragte in ihrem Bericht auf
doch der Krieg verändert die Sicht auf
die Dinge neue Kampfjets und
Transporthubschrauber sind vom 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen auf den Weg
gebracht doch die Truppe spürt davon
noch nichts ich muss leider feststellen
dass im Jahr 2022 von diesem
Sondervermögen noch kein Euro und kein
Cent ausgegeben wurde und deswegen
verbinde ich das auch mit der Forderung
dass dieses wichtige Geld für die
Bundeswehr zügig in der Truppe ankommt
die ausgerufene Zeitenwende sie stockt
die werbeauftragte fordert mehr Tempo
bei der Beschaffung weniger Behäbigkeit
mehr Mut in Verteidigungsministerium und
Beschaffungsamt Zustimmung von Ampel und
Opposition es brauche nicht nur mehr
Geld sondern ein neues Denken
wenn wir Dinge brauchen müssen Sie
sofort eingekauft werden das heißt wir
müssen nicht bei allem eine große
Ausschreibung machen das erlaubt
übrigens dass die europäische
Gesetzgebung wenn es um Sicherheit geht
und das müssen die Menschen die das
Umsetzen verstehen Zeiten wenn da es
nicht nur mehr Geld sondern heißt zügig
zackig umzusetzen wenn sich die
beschaffungsstrukturen nicht ändern dann
wird sich auch in der Beschreibung des
Zustandes der Bundeswehr im nächsten
lehrbericht nichts geändert haben der
Wahl muss sich die Truppe Strecken oft
bis an die Belastungsgrenze zu wenig
Personal für neue Anforderungen an der
Ostflanke Eurofighter nach Rumänien
Corvetten in die Ostsee Übungen und
Truppenverstärkung in Litauen
zeitenwände bedeutet auch mehr Personal
doch zu wenige kommen zur Bundeswehr zu
viele brechen ab wohl auch weil die
Bundeswehr schlecht ausgestattet wie sie
ist wenig attraktiv erscheint in den
sozialen Netzwerken liest man übers auf
wenn du Panzerfahrer werden willst die
überall hin und nicht zu Bundeswehr denn
dort gibt es kaum noch Panzer im
Panzerbataillon en muss jetzt aufpassen
dass die Bundeswehr nicht in den
Teufelskreis Gerät auf der einen Seite
wird sie ausgelaugt mit Blick auf die
Verpflichtungen an der NATO Ostflanke
die Abgaben an die Ukraine und auf der
anderen Seite muss sie eigentlich
Personal gewinnen die werbeauftragte
sagt es gelte das Momentum des derzeit
hohen gesellschaftlichen Rückhalts für
die Bundeswehr zu nutzen um sie besser
auszurüsten die zeitenwände mache es
unausweichlich dass sich was verändert
im Zusammenhang mit dem Krieg gegen die
Ukraine sorgte dann heute noch einen
Zwischenfall über dem Schwarzen Meer
verschlagzahlen darin verwickelt waren
eine unbemannte US-Drohne und zwei
russische Kampfjets hier Archivaufnahmen
eines solchen drohnentyps vom US-Militär
hieß es zum Ablauf die russischen
Kampfjets hätten sich der Drohne genährt
und einer habe ihren Propeller gestreift
us-kräfte hätten die Drohne daraufhin
zum Absturz gebracht
die russische Seite bestreitet jede
Verantwortung es habe keinen direkten
Kontakt gegeben die USA hingegen nannten
das Verhalten der Russen gefährlich und
unprofessionell MRT wissen das sind ja
in der Tat die Art von Zwischenfällen
oder Provokationen die die Sorge vor
einer Eskalation auslösen also bei der
dann russisches und westliches Militär
direkt gegeneinander agieren wie wird
dieser Vorfall denn in Washington
eingeschätzt
ja in den öffentlichen Äußerungen bemüht
man sich sehr darum dass das eben nicht
eskaliert weil man nicht genau weiß was
die Absicht hinter diesem Manöver war
das Pentagon sagt sehr klar das muss
volle Absicht erst einmal gewesen sein
30 bis 40 Minuten sein die Kampfjets mit
der Drohne gewissermaßen unterwegs
gewesen hätten sie Kraftstoff auf diese
Drohne gewissermaßen runtergeschüttet
und hätten dann eben den Propeller
berührt und dadurch sei dann die Drohne
manövriereunfähig geworden und zum
Absturz gebracht worden Moskau
bestreitet das eben nun hat hier keiner
erwartet dass Moskau sagt ja das waren
wir tut uns leid ähm das Entscheidende
ist jetzt herauszufinden was die
Intention war waren es nur die Piloten
die im Grunde genommen diesen ich sag
mal salopp dann hingelegt haben oder
hatten sie Befehle von oben genau das zu
tun das Erkunden die Amerikaner jetzt
Sie prüfen ob Sie Videomaterial haben
von diesem Vorfall und dann auch
freigeben können möglicherweise sie
haben den russischen Botschafter
eingestellt um ihm sehr klar zu machen
dass man das nicht akzeptiert und je
nachdem wenn der Befehl von oben kam
dann würde man sich eventuell auch
darauf einrichten müssen dass es
ähnliche Vorfälle in den nächsten Tagen
und Wochen gibt um eine Eskalation zu
provozieren und die kann natürlich
versehentlich dann auch sehr schnell
passieren danke schön für die
Einschätzung einmal nach Washington
kommen wir noch mal zurück zur
Bundeswehr die werbeauftragte klagte
heute auch über Kasernen die kein WLAN
haben dafür aber kaputte Toiletten woran
erinnert einen das an deutsche Schulen
natürlich warum soll es jeden in deren
Händen und Köpfen unsere Zukunft liegt
auch besser ergehen als jeden die unser
Land verteidigen sollen
Bundeswehr und Bildung die Stiefkinder
der Republik in beiden Bereichen geht es
vor allem um langfristige Investitionen
die sind halt auch politisch nicht so
attraktiv wie kurzfristige
Konsumausgaben
auf dem Bildungsgipfel in Berlin konnte
heute noch mal über all die Probleme
geredet werden die aber ja im Grunde
längst bekannt sind es wenn Klass
beginnt seinen Bericht in einer
Grundschule in Baden-Württemberg
mehr als 65 Jahre Altersunterschied
liegen zwischen ihm und seinem
Erstklässlern 73 ist Paul proscha wäre
eigentlich schon längst den Pension doch
jedes Jahr aufs Neue kommt der Anruf des
Schulleiters wir brauchen dich hier
dringend an der Schule weiß ich zum
Beispiel auch dass letztes Jahr
Kolleginnen sieben Stunden mehr
arbeiteten weil als sie niemand da war
und ich habe den ganzen grundschulsport
bis auf eine klasse jetzt und eine
Klasse in Englisch er springte die
Bresche gleich das aus was die Politik
versäumt hat für genügend Lehrer zu
sorgen den Unterricht irgendwie
sicherstellen eine tagtägliche
Herausforderung für seinen Schulleiter
in Heitersheim in Baden-Württemberg in
diesem Schuljahr haben sie jetzt noch
kein einziges Mal geschafft auch nur den
Pflichtunterricht komplett abzudecken
derzeit fehlen rund 10% des benötigten
Personals habe ich keine Zeit ich muss
gucken dass der Laden irgendwie läuft
aber ein gewisses Maß man Verwunderung
schwingt dort natürlich schon mit dass
ich seit Jahren strukturell nichts
ändert ein Bildungsgipfel mit
Teilnehmern aus Politik Wissenschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft soll aus Sicht der
Bundesbildungsministerin jetzt der
Auftakt sein in eine bessere Zukunft
dabei ist der Lehrer Mangel zehntausende
fehlen bundesweit nur eines von
unzähligen Problemen das Aufholen von
lernrückständen durch Corona die
schleppende Digitalisierung die
Integration geflüchteter die Defizite
sind vielschichtig und riesengroß wir
sind nicht da wo wir sein müssen und wo
wir sein wollen wir sind jetzt an einem
entscheidenden Punkt
es ist wichtig dass wir jetzt gemeinsam
starten doch dass das mit dem gemeinsam
in der Bildungspolitik so eine Sache ist
zeigt sich auch heute wieder nur zwei
von 16 landeskultusministern sind da
beschwichtigungsversuch
natürlich waren alle eingeladen alles
andere wäre ja auch nicht sinnvoll
nichtsdestotrotz von dem Setting dass
wir heute haben also wir haben ja auch
Panel Diskussionen und es ist ja der
Anfang wir wollen ja dann arbeiten kann
man auch nicht unbedingt erwarten dass
alle da sitzen und nach Berlin kommen
das nicht ohne dass wir nicht eine
konkrete Agenda haben sondern nur eine
lapidare Einladung zu einem sogenannten
Bildungsgipfel wo die Themen nicht klar
sind wo die Zielstellungen wenig klar
ist Kritik am Gipfel kommt aber nicht
nur aus der Union auch Landesminister
aus den ampelparteien fehlen für
Baden-Württemberg erklärt der
Ministerpräsident das mit Blick auf den
Lehrermangel so
sie jetzt nicht wie man so ein Problem
durch irgendeine Berliner Bildungsgipfel
verbessern kann das nach diesem Tag
bleibt ist die Ankündigung aus Berlin in
einer breit besetzten Task Force gegen
die Probleme anzuarbeiten und Schüler
die hoffen dass vieles bald besser wird
das Unterricht tatsächlich stattfinden
kann man fühlt sich schon irgendwo ein
bisschen allein gelassen so also
natürlich tut man sich selber nachholen
vielleicht auch mit seinen
Klassenkameraden aber wer schon besser
wenn da vielleicht halt mehr Lehrer da
werden auch weil die Zahl der Schüler in
den nächsten Jahren noch mal deutlich
ansteigen wird
nach bei Theo Collin Berlin ja einen
quasi halb blockierter Gipfel da fragt
man sich schon was soll das ja in der
Tat und das muss man beide Seiten Bund
und Länder fragen warum bietet die
Bundesbildungsministerin durch
unzureichende Vorbereitung die Chance
zur Blockade eines solchen
Bildungsgipfels solche Veranstaltungen
lassen sich ja nicht endlos wiederholen
angesichts der Dramatik der Probleme hat
Frau stark Watzinger da der Sache ein
bildungsbären Dienste Wiesen
gleichzeitig aber müssen sich die
ferngebliebenen Bildungsminister und
Ministerin der ländervorwerfen lassen
dass sie die ungeschickte Gipfel
Vorbereitung eher politisch genutzt
haben man könnte auch sagen missbraucht
haben um die Bildungsministerin aus dem
Bund per Blockade zu blamieren der
tiefen Krise jedenfalls scheint beides
nicht angemessen
der Tag nun will die Bundesministerin ja
eine Task Force Team Bildung Gründen
aber team building schalte nun genau das
woran es auf allen Ebenen hapert und es
gerne nochmal wirklich viele
Zuständigkeiten in der Bildungspolitik
ja ganz genau Bildung in der
Bundesrepublik ist ja bekanntermaßen
Ländersache und das heißt Deutschland
hat 16 unterschiedliche Bildungssysteme
wir jemals in ein anderes Bundesland
umgezogen ist der weiß was das heißt der
Bund darf den Ländern nicht reinreden
und diese tasforce Bildung klingt für
mich ein wenig nach dem zarten
versuchter zumindest mitreden zu wollen
es ist aber nicht nur diese staatlich
strukturelle Zersplitterung es ist zu
zeigen viele OSZE Bildungsstudien vor
allem die mangelnde Einigkeit und die
widerstreitenden politischen
Vorstellungen über den richtigen
Bildungsweg starten mit einem
bildungskonsens die schneiden oft besser
ab als Deutschland und dabei ist es dann
egal ob sie föderal oder
zentralstaatlich geregelt sind
interessant danke schön nach Berlin und
jetzt geht's mit den Nachrichten weiter
Hein zunächst mit dem Streiks heute
ist öffentlichen Dienstes hatte die
Gewerkschaft Verdi heute zur
bundesweiten bahnstreckt im
Gesundheitswesen aufgerufen und 13.000
Beschäftigte aus Krankenhäusern
Pflegeeinrichtungen und dem
Rettungsdienst legten nach Verdi Angaben
in mehreren Bundesländern ihre Arbeit
nieder die nächste Verhandlungsrunde
zwischen Gewerkschaft und Arbeitgebern
ist für Ende des Monats vorgesehen
der gewaltsame Tod einer 12-Jährigen aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen sorgt für Entsetzen
auch weil die Tat offenbar von zwei
zwölf und 13 Jahre alten Mädchen
begangen wurde die ist auch gestanden
haben alle drei kannten sich wie Polizei
und Staatsanwaltschaft heute bekannt
gaben das Opfer war am Sonntag nahe
eines Radweges erstochen aufgefunden
worden zum Motiv für die Tat machten die
Ermittler mit Verweis auf die noch straf
unmündigen Kinder keine Angaben
die EU-Kommission will den Strommarkt
reformieren sie zielt ab auf den Ausbau
erneuerbare Energien und den Schutz der
Verbraucher sie sollen dem Vorschlag
zufolge unter anderem von langfristigen
Verträgen profitieren das Europäische
Parlament und die Länder müssen den
Vorschlägen der Kommission noch
endgültig aushandeln beschlossen hat das
Parlament heute eine Verordnung die für
jedes Mitgliedsland verbindliche Ziele
zur Verringerung von
Treibhausgasemissionen festlegt und zwar
im Straßenverkehr beim Heizen von
Gebäuden und in der Landwirtschaft die
Treibhausgasemissionen sollen demnach
EU-weit bis 2030 um 40% gegenüber dem
Stand von 2005 verringert werden
die australische Marine soll mit
atomgetriebenen U-Booten ausgerüstet
werden im Rahmen einer Zusammenarbeit
zwischen den USA Australien und
Großbritannien
US-Präsident beiden betonte bei einem
Treffen der drei Staats- und
Regierungschefs im kalifornischen San
Diego das ist um Boote mit Atom Antrieb
und nicht mit Atomwaffen gehe die
sicherheitsallianz diene einer freien
und offenen indopazifischen Region sie
gilt auch als ein Gegengewicht zum
wachsenden Einfluss Chinas dort China
kritisierte die Pläne als Denkweise des
Kalten Krieges
die Bedrohung durch Russland hat die
Europäer ja zusammenrücken lassen das
überwölkt gelegentlich welche
politischen Konflikte innerhalb der EU
wählen man redet eben derzeit mehr über
Panzer als etwa über die Prinzipien der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit doch das
Gerichtsurteil das heute in Warschau
gefällt wurde wirft ein schlaglich
darauf wie groß die
gesellschaftspolitischen Unterschiede in
der EU sein können verurteilt wurde eine
Frau wegen Beihilfe zu einem
Schwangerschaftsabbruch der Fall hat
nicht nur in Polen Aufsehen erregt das
Europäische Parlament hat übrigens
letztes Jahr beklagt dass seit der
Verschärfung des abtreibungsrechts in
Polen mindestens sechs Frauen durch
Schwangerschaftskomplikationen ihr Leben
verloren weil Ärzte sich nicht trauten
Ihnen zu helfen
Steger berichtet aus Warschau
sie hat und sie will Aufmerksamkeit für
ihre Sache entsprechend gekleidet nimmt
sie das Urteil entgegen schuldig und
vorbestraft Justina virginska zu 8
Monaten gemeinnützige Arbeit verurteilt
weil sie einer Frau abtreibungspillen
besorte
ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht schuldig
ich hörte zu als ob es nicht über mich
gewesen wäre dieses Urteil nehme ich
nicht an
Proteste gegen das Urteil laut
Menschenrechtsorganisationen wird ein
Präzedenzfall in Polen geschaffen Strafe
für Beihilfe zur Abtreibung
dies stellt Polen in eine Reihe mit
repressiven Ländern die Menschenrechte
nicht vollständig respektieren
einschließlich der Frauenrechte
es ist ein Fall der das gespaltene Polen
zeigt auch Abtreibungsgegner sind
aufgezogen mit Babygeschrei vom Band
das ist ein großer Schritt nach vorne
wenn es um Gerechtigkeit geht für
Personen die verantwortlich für das
Töten von Kindern sind
Gründerin einer Aktivistengruppe viele
Frauen baten um Hilfe auch die um deren
falls ging ungewollt schwanger in einer
gewalttätigen Beziehung hat sie der Frau
Pillen geschickt der Mann fand es heraus
zeigte Justina virginska an
als ich die Tabletten verschickt habe
war ich mir im Klaren darüber was ich
tue ich kenne die Gesetze in Polen ich
wusste dass ich meinen rechtlichen
Schutz riskiere
in Polen gibt es kaum legale
Abtreibungen seitdem das
Verfassungsgericht Ende 2020 das Recht
noch verschärfte Abbruch nur noch legal
bei Vergewaltigung und Lebensgefahr für
die Mutter ansonsten droht nicht der
Frau aber dem helferstrafe viele Ärzte
sind derart verunsichert dass sie auch
legale Abbrüche verweigern wie zuletzt
im Fall eine 14-jährigen von einem
Verwandten vergewaltigt
nachgestellte Szenen des polnischen
Privat-TV Ärzte verweigern den Abbruch
erst mit Unterstützung einer
frauenrechtsgruppe findet sie einen Arzt
dieses Kind hat zwei Dramen erlitten es
wurde vergewaltigt auch noch von einer
nahestehenden Person und dann hat es ein
drittes Päckchen von Ärzte Kollegen
bekommen die ihm nicht helfen wollten
Proteste als eine Frau 2021 an einer
Sepsis verstirbt weil Ärzte ihren
Sterbenden Fötus nicht abtreiben sondern
den Tod des Kindes abwarten sie hatte
Angst sie hat mir noch SMS geschrieben
die von Justina veginska verschickten
Pillen wurden von der Frau nicht einmal
eingenommen sie erlitt davor eine
Fehlgeburt dennoch der Schuldspruch
Justina virginska will Berufung einlegen
weitermachen und sich nicht
einschüchtern lassen
als er kürzlich danach gefragt wurde wie
dann die Aussichten für Neuwagen mit
e-fuel Antrieb sein sprach
volkswagenchef Oliver Blume von einer
Zitat nischenrolle für Kleinserien
Hersteller diese Nische sorgt politisch
allerdings weiterhin für mächtig Wirbel
der weil die Autobauer sich längst auf
die Elektromobilität als künftige
hauptantriebsform einstellen das wurde
auch bei der Bilanzpressekonferenz des
VW-Konzerns heute deutlich in den
nächsten Jahren will VW einen
dreistelligen Milliardenbetrag allein in
E-Mobilität und Digitalisierung stecken
mehr als in jedem anderen Bereich
wie sich Deutschlands größter Autobauer
heute präsentierte hat Oliver verfolgt
Zentrum steht eine neue Oliver Blume
seit rund 7 Monaten Link er den
VW-Konzern hat so manche Entscheidung
seines Vorgängers korrigiert der Erfolg
gibt ihm recht zunächst erstmal haben
wir einen sehr solides Jahr hingelegt
berücksichtigen die ganzen externen
Herausforderungen die wir im letzten
Jahr hatten Ukraine Krieg aber auch die
Störung im Lieferantennetzwerk Corona
schaut Downs in China wir haben nach wie
vor Herausforderungen und haben aber
einen klaren Plan dafür und deshalb
blicken wir zuversichtlich in das Jahr
2023 um 22,5% steigert Volkswagen im
vergangenen Jahr den Gewinn auf
insgesamt 2,65 Milliarden Euro dabei
nahm der Fahrzeug verkauft um 6,8% ab
man hat halt eben keine Rabatte mehr
weitergegeben an die Kunden weil einfach
der die Nachfrage so hoch war und das
Angebot so gering dass man die Autos zu
einem sehr teuren Preis verkaufen konnte
die deutsche Autoindustrie einfach ein
VW steht vor gigantischen Aufgaben und
Problemen der Umbau zu elektromobilität
ist im vollen Gange aber ist der Weg
richtig zwar will die EU mehrheitlich ab
2035 den Verkauf von neuen Verbrennern
verbieten doch die Forderung des
deutschen Verkehrsministers mit
synthetischen Kraftstoffen betriebene
Verbrenner weiterhin zuzulassen steht im
Raum keine wirklich Alternative für den
VW-Chef synthetische Kraftstoffe stehen
nicht den Konkurrenz zur
Elektromobilität sondern konzentrieren
sich auf den hohen Bestand an Verbrenner
Fahrzeugen die wir auf der Welt haben
aber die große Richtung geht in Richtung
Elektromobilität weil diese Motoren in
Zukunft den Verbrennungsmotoren
überlegen sein werden deshalb investiert
Volkswagen in den kommenden fünf Jahren
allein 122 Milliarden Euro in digital
Dosierung und Elektrifizierung nicht
ohne Risiko
elektromobilität ist jetzt erstmal die
Zukunft was in 10 bis 15 Jahren ist auch
dann das technologierad nicht wieder neu
sich dreht und wir halt eben wieder
Alternativen zur Verfügung haben das
schließlich überhaupt nicht aus
aufrichtige Pferd setzen und wo Blume
der sich selbst als Stratege nicht als
Visionär sieht verkündete gerade den
Aufbau einer batteriefertigung in Kanada
der Volkswagen Konzern hat in
Nordamerika noch viel Potential wir
haben aktuell 4% Marktanteil wollen das
deutlich steigern und deshalb
unternehmen wir diese Aktivitäten die
Subventionen die es dort in Nordamerika
gibt unterstützen das natürlich und
machen dann Vorhaben deutlich
wirtschaftlicher und was ist mit China
für VW der größte Absatzmarkt rund 35%
seiner Fahrzeuge verkauft der Konzern im
Land der aufgehenden Sonne würde dieses
Geschäft einbrechen hätte der Autobauer
ein Riesenproblem so wird in China der
ID3 schon zum halben Preis verkauft um
konkurrenzfähig mit chinesischen
Fahrzeugen zu bleiben
mit Wirtschaft geht es bei dir jetzt
auch noch mal weiter und da schauen wir
heute ein weiteres Mal auf die Zinsen es
gibt neue Daten zur Entwicklung bei den
Bauzinsen worauf müssen sich
Immobilienkäufe bei der Finanzierung
einstellen Frank bedmann na ganz
generell dass die Zeit der günstigen
Bauzinsen vorbei ist und darauf dass die
Hypothekenzinsen stärker als zu lang
letzt schwanken werden noch zu
Wochenbeginn stieg das Baugeld für
zehnjährige Finanzierungen auf über 4%
doch das ändert sich gerade von Tag zu
Tag heute liegen sie wieder leicht unter
4% eines scheint aber sicher
Hypothekenzinsen wie wir sie hatten von
teilweise unter einem Prozent werden wir
so schnell nicht wiedersehen und wir
sind die Einschätzungen wie es mit den
Zinsen weitergeht
ja das ist eine der spannendsten Fragen
derzeit überhaupt und die Meinungen dazu
gehen weit auseinander in den
zurückliegenden Monaten hat sich ja
alles auf das Zurückdrängen der
Inflation konzentriert die Insolvenz der
Silicon Valley Bank hat uns nun aber vor
Augen geführt die Zinswende vor allem
das Tempo mit dem die Leitzinsen zuletzt
angehoben worden bürgt erhebliche
Risiken Kurse von Anleihen und Aktien
gaben nach Banken müssen teilweise
Milliarden auf ihre Wertpapiere im
eigenen Bestand abschreiben andere wie
die besagte US-Bank sind gezwungen
Staatsanleihen mit erheblichen Verlusten
zu verkaufen die Notenbanken kommen ins
Grübeln was tun weiter Kurs halten im
Kampf gegen die Inflation oder nun doch
die Leitzinsen weniger stark Strafen um
nicht tatsächlich eine handfeste Krise
am Bankenmarkt auszulösen die EZB wird
bereits übermorgen bei ihrer nächsten
Sitzung darauf eine Antwort finden
müssen Frank vielen Dank
Biathlon Weltmeisterin Denise Hermann
Wick beendet ihre Karriere schon als
Langläuferin erfolgreich holte die
34-Jährige dann im Biathlon Gold bei den
Olympischen Spielen im Peking und jüngst
bei der Heim WM in Oberhof Gold im
Sprint am Sonntag soll hermannweg ihren
letzten Auftritt beim Massenstart in
Oslo haben
Karl Geiger hat beim Skisprung Weltcup
in Lillehammer das Podest verpasst am
Ende landete der Oberstdorfer auf dem
fünften Platz zum Drittplatzierten
Manuel Fettner fehlten ihm nur 1,9
Punkte tages-sieger wurde der Norweger
graner-rüd der Weltcup führende sprang
im zweiten Durchgang auf
139einhalb Meter zweiter wurde der
Österreicher Stefan Kraft
wenn die Kunst jeweils auch ein Spiegel
ihrer Zeit ist ist dass man natürlich
dass auch dort die Digitalisierung
längst Einzug gehalten hat und die Kunst
da aber genauso rasanten Veränderungen
unterliegt manche Video-Installationen
die vor 20 Jahren noch Avantgarde waren
wirken heute gerade zu Retro der
Düsseldorfer Kunstpalast widmetes widmet
sich jetzt einen Künstler dessen
Arbeiten hoch aktuell sind rifig Anna
doll gilt als einer der visionärsten auf
dem Gebiet der datenkunst die er mit
künstlicher Intelligenz verbindet
konsequent zeitgenössisch sozusagen
deutsche Färber hat sich die Werkschau
angesehen
Daten Pixel Algorithmen hier
halluzinieren Maschinen eine
datenskulptur von refig anadol sie
besteht aus zwei Millionen Bildern
aufgenommen von weltraumteleskopen
bearbeitet von künstlicher Intelligenz
diese neuronalen Netzwerke sind in der
Lage eben selbstständig neue Bilder zu
produzieren und das ist das Besondere
dafür braucht man sehr hohe Datenmengen
damit das funktioniert und er als
Künstler sucht sich komponiert quasi die
besten
Grafik anadol ist Pionier der datenkunst
mit Algorithmen schafft er Welten
zwischen Realität und Traum mit 300
Millionen Naturfotos hat er für dieses
Werk die Computer gefüttert das Ergebnis
Formen die natürlich wirken aber
künstlich geschaffen worden
komplett KI es ist wirklich inspirierend
Daten werden zum Pigment für Gemälde man
wird in den Geist einer Maschine
hineingesogen fliegt in die Erinnerungen
und Träume eine Maschine
der Künstler aber entscheidet über die
Datengrundlage hier 1,3 Millionen Fotos
von Nationalparks über Farbauswahl
Abstraktionsgrad über die Länge des
Bluts Mensch und Maschine schaffen
gemeinsam Neues
man guckt so da drauf und man ist so gar
nicht mehr hier in dem Raum sondern man
ist so in dem Bild drin das ist schon
ganz klasse aber wenn sowas auch noch
nie vorher gesehen hat also ich
jedenfalls in der Form noch nicht rund
um die Welt bespielt Refik an adol-räume
mit Kunst aus künstlicher Intelligenz
gerade erst auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum
mit diesem Werk
in Berlin präsentierte er eine Arbeit
bei der die Bewegungsdaten der Menschen
in der Ausstellung mit berechnet wurden
[Musik]
wir alle reden über
GPT und andere Formen und wir sind uns
glaube ich alle einig dass wir gerade an
so einer Schwelle stehen wo irgendetwas
passiert was neu ist und ähm Kanada ist
da ganz vorne dabei in Düsseldorf ist
Trafik einer doll bis Mai zu sehen viele
zücken gleich ihr Handy manche gehen es
meditativer an das Museum bietet auch
Yogakurse vor den Werken
[Musik]
das war von uns mit der Anstalt geht's
weiter 15 meldet sich dann wohl Schmiede
mit unserem britischen all Update bis
morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen wird der kälteste Tag
dieser Woche denn schon zum Ende der
Woche wird's von Spanien und Frankreich
hier bei uns im Mitteleuropa wieder
deutlich milder jetzt in der Nacht
sinken die Temperaturen auf zwei Grad in
Ostfriesland und bis -3 Grad am
Alpenrand und so geht der Regen im Laufe
der Nacht hier in Süddeutschland mehr
und mehr in Schnee über und auch im
Westen kann es schneien wie viel von dem
Schnee da morgen noch übrig bleibt
müssen wir abwarten in den
Mittelgebirgen wird's aber in jedem Fall
weiß und an der Nordseeküste gibt es
Schnee Regenschauer und heute Nacht sind
auch einige Gewitter dabei machen sie
sich auf Glätte gefasst durch Schnee
durch Schneematsch oder auch durch
überfrierende Nässe morgen ziehen die
Schnee und Schnee Regenfälle rasch aus
Deutschland ab da wird der Nachmittag
ganz freundlich vormittags allerdings
kann es im nördlichen Brandenburg und
auch in Schleswig-Holstein noch für
einzelne Gewitter reichen bei einem Wind
meist aus westlichen Richtungen die
Temperaturen steigen morgen auf vier
Grad im Sauerland oder auch in der
Oberpfalz und bis 11 Grad am Oberrhein
und dann wird es deutlich wärmer schon
am Samstag steigen die Temperaturen bis
12 Grad an der Küste und 20 Grad am
Oberrhein das wird nicht nur wärmer
sondern auch wieder trockener einzig
hier im Nordwesten an der Nordseeküste
und später vielleicht dann auch am
Niederrhein kann es in den nächsten
Tagen noch etwas Regen geben ich wünsche
Ihnen einen schönen Abend